[Music]
the instantly was a bit smaller as sex
counselors and and myself as acting mere
and of course David a deputy mere and
two other counselors over at
Passchendaele they're over there with
approximately forty RSA members from
around their district so the
representation from this district in
patient dollars is very big on the 12th
of this month there will be a at the car
push senator there will be a
commemoration service of which the just
about all the remainder of counselors
will will be there we need Ooty has is
going to deliver a speech on behalf of
the council vehicle
great to see giant steps starting to
happen for higher point on that
regeneration area we passed yesterday
the wall in the river on the north side
of the river to be strengthened ready
for the development on the site that
which used to be the Hansons mall that
will take place hopefully in November
the first side will be tuned on that
in regards to the approval of the
stopping of the roads that was also
passed yesterday at Council I think that
that's a huge psychological step not
only for Kayaba liver for the whole
district once those roads start to
disappear and it returns back to green
and all the the new plan starts to come
together this is really going to sit a
cop way back on the path of of really
being healed
we didn't approve $30,000 for next year
for the food forest hugely successful
project with the planning of trees and
250 people tuning up a couple of weeks
ago to get that well underway so now
there are some some funding in which
people can draw on and the lease is now
signed for that land but that's
fantastic news for some very
hard-working trustees who have put that
together
[Music]